in a city packed with iconic skyscrapers
the equitable building in the heart of
New York City's financial district might
not seem to stand out but according to
legend this skyscraper was once
considered so obscenely large that it
led to the first major zoning law in the
United States and because of that law it
was the last skyscraper of its kind when
it was completed in 1915 the equitable
building was the largest office building
in the world
and an engineering marvel the building
had one problem it was too big designed
to maximize rentable office space it was
basically a 40 storey 8 shaped box
crammed onto an acre sized city block
when it was built
New Yorkers were in an uproar over the
evil effect of its size neighbors
complained of the enormous shadow that
casts nearby buildings and streets into
complete darkness meanwhile developers
worried that a glut of these huge office
buildings would hurt real estate values
at the time New York had no laws
restricting the size or height of office
buildings but his new technology was
pushing skyscrapers like the equitable
building to unprecedented scale the
outcry for regulation reached a breaking
point then something happened within a
year a law was passed that effectively
made skyscrapers like the equitable
building impossible to build again it
was called the 1916 zoning resolution
and it was the first comprehensive
zoning law in the United States
to be clear the equitable building
didn't directly cause the 1916 zoning
resolution it was simply the ultimate
scapegoat in a debate that had been
heating up for years as new technology
made skyscrapers bigger and bigger
instead of enacting a fixed height limit
like other cities had done the drafters
of the resolution developed an ingenious
plan based on something called a setback
principle here's how it worked
depending on the district a building's
height could not exceed a certain ratio
to the width of the street in a one and
a half district for example the maximum
height was limited to one and a half
times the street width a building could
gain extra height however if it were set
back from the street in a one and a half
district a building could rise another
three feet for each foot that it was set
back from the street furthermore in any
district 25% of the lot had no height
limit at all working within these
constraints architects began to
creatively conform designs and what
became a characteristic style starting
full-width at street level and tapering
off in steps as it rose in height and
once you're aware of it you start to see
it throughout Manhattan
and the intended effect of making New
York's dense streets seem more open for
the most part actually works the zoning
resolution went beyond height limits -
it also set rules for how land could be
used in specific areas of the city such
as prohibiting industrial work in
residential or business districts around
the same time other American cities
began to adopt similar zoning plans six
years later Congress passed a law based
partly on New York City's example as a
blueprint for zoning nationwide by the
1960s New York had grown significantly
and so the city passed a new resolution
modifying the setback principle to
accommodate for new building designs
meanwhile the equitable building now a
historic landmark and undergoing a major
renovation is a monument to a bygone era
one whose excesses led to New York's
iconic skyline which will never look at
the same way again
you